good afternoon
we have just finished a meeting convened
by the African Union on the dramatic
situation in Sudan
bring together the United Nations the
league of Arab states egad and the
European Union
as well as representatives from a number
of countries that are deeply committed
to solving the crisis
there was a strong consensus on
condemning the ongoing fighting in Sudan
and calling for secession of hostilities
as an immediate priority I appeal for a
ceasefire to take place for at least
three days marking the Eid al-fitrus
celebrations
to allow civilians Trapped In conflict
zones to escape and to seek medical
treatment food and other essential
supplies
these must be the first step in
providing respite from the fighting and
Paving the way for a permanent ceasefire
I have been personally engaged in doing
everything possible to make it happen
the secession was still it is must be
followed by serious dialogue allowing
for the successful transition starting
with the appointment of a civilian
government
the fighting must stop immediately
I am deeply concerned about the terrible
toll on civilians the appalling
humanitarian situation and the
horrifying prospects of further
escalation
hundreds of people have been killed and
injured fighting in urban areas is
particularly dangerous for civilians
including children who have repeatedly
been forced to shelter in schools and
evacuate from hospitals and the fire
disease completely outrageous
humanitarian oppressions are virtually
impossible warehouses vehicles and other
humanitarian assets have been attacked
looted and seized
targeting humanitarian work and said
assets must end and I remind all parties
of their obligations and international
law including ensuring Safety and
Security of humanitarian Aid workers
I'm also extremely worried about the
situation of United Nations personnel
many of whom are trapped in their homes
in areas of active conflicts we are
doing everything in our power to be able
to support them
I will continue to use my good offices
in close coordination with our partners
to establish a ceasefire the escalate
tension and start political talks
the United Nations stands with the
Sudanese people in school support of
their wishes for a peaceful secure
future and the return to the democratic
transition thank you
thank you very much
gone what will the Catalyst be to ensure
that a third attempt will succeed two
ceasefires two attempted ceasefires have
come and gone what will the Catalyst be
for this third attempt to succeed I
think there is a strong reason for all
all parties of the conflict are Muslim
we are living a very important moment in
the Muslim calendar I think this is the
right moment for a ceasefire to hold and
this is fire is absolutely crucial at
the present moment we have been in
contact with the parties we believe it
is possible but everybody must be United
in putting pressure for the ceasefire to
take effectively place thank you
foreign